hello everybody and welcome to another
python 3 basics tutorial video this
video is going to be covering the basics
of at least understanding classes in
python for the most part i just want you
to understand how to like read and
follow along with what's happening in
someone else's class not necessarily
to teach you guys how to write really
good classes and all that the idea of
class
or classes is to kind of encase a group
it's almost like a
a way
you could use classes instead of modules
um that's usually the way i see people
using it
is to save a
almost like as if they were writing like
scripts like like people do with java
let's say
but they have classes and then
underneath the classes they've got all
their functions
and it's just kind of treated as if
class is equal to a module almost but
anyway um i just want to show you guys
how to follow them class is really just
a
a way of grouping things together i
suppose but you can do some really neat
things with classes and but actually i
would kind of consider classes more of
an intermediate kind of thing
but i think at least understanding them
is is good for basics so uh with that
let's go ahead and get started uh one of
the simplest things i can think of to
use as an example would be to create a
class
and make that class calculator
you don't have to put any parameters
here just colon and that's it
so class calculator so our calculator
class uh should contain obviously some
pretty simple uh things like what it
what does a calculator do well at its
very basics a calculator should at least
add subtract multiply and divide
should be able to do all those things so
we definitely want our calculator to be
able to do that so let's go ahead and do
that so
for addition we'll say define addition
and for addition we're just going to say
we can only have two variables
so for addition we have x y
and we'll say added equals x plus y
and then we'll do print
added okay so that's our definition
uh but now we also need this calculator
to be able to do subtraction so define
subtraction
and again x y
and now what we do is we'll say sub
equals x minus y
okay
then we'll go ahead and print
sub
continuing right along we also need to
be able to do multiplication so to find
multiplication
x y again
colon
and now we'll say mult
equals x times y
finally we want to be able to do
division define division
x y
colon
and div
equals x divided by y
and print
diff
okay so now we've got
our basic calculator class all the
things that are
encompassed within our class
and let me just
push this up one little bit and now
let's say we actually wanted a user
class so an example of someone using
class would calculator you would
basically do the following calculator
dot and let's say we wanted to do
multiplication calculator dot
multiplication
x y we want to do 3 5. so that would be
how you call the multiplication division
of multiplication
thinking like division as in like a
division of like a company anyway that's
how you would do multiplication
um
within our calculator class so let's go
ahead and save and run that
and
oh it just so happens we never printed
out molds wow of all the ones that we
didn't do so anyway print
mult okay now let's run it and sure
enough
one multiplication gave us 15.
now we can call the other ones so
calculator dot addition
5 2
and that's going to give us a seven
calculator dot subtraction
uh ten nine oops ten nine one you guys
get the idea um
so
uh that's basically how you can kind of
read and understand a class
like i said there's some other things
that people do with classes uh to give
them quite a bit of
more functionality to them but for now
uh these are just kind of the basics of
a class and how to understand like what
people are doing
when they use classes so hopefully that
was helpful for you guys if you have any
questions or comments feel free to leave
them in the comments section as always
thanks for watching thanks for all the
support and subscriptions and until next
time